chance of junk this is start number
three what have you seen in the first
two well i really like his command both
this curveball and the slider but really
it's it's that four-seam fastball it's
gonna be important my go-to is for him
to have success today against this astro
lineup here's your don alvarez alvarez
again one big swing away from a 100 rbi
season there goes altuve the pitch is
outside stassey's throw is wide and
altuve has his fifth stolen base of the
year jose altuve
who was off with a 3-2 pitch to alex
bregman steals a base with alvarez at
the plate junk has fallen behind again
it's 2-0 on alvarez who crushes one oh
my goodness deep to center field give
him a hundo
100 rbi season for the first time in his
career with a two-run bolt to center
field
456. we've seen a lot of baseball in
that ballpark i don't think i've seen
one rushed up onto that berm in center
field that quickly ever two homers
runner goes chopper wong started to his
right back to his left gets the out at
first
but the astros play long ball i mean
really long ball jordan alvarez and luis
garcia's at right-hander on the mound
for your houston astros he is continuing
to pitch well the governor has been
taken off and he has looked fantastic 26
starts this season in 28 games
reclaimed by los angeles how about
bregman on a smash to third altuve with
a jump throw for the double play
brandon marsh was right on top of altuve
as the astros able to turn two on a
smash by jack mayfield
and another four pitch walk
so garcia who hasn't walked more than
three in any start this year has walked
two here in the first inning
phil gosling first pitch swinging sends
one into shallow right coming on
mccormick he looked at altuve for a
while before he finally took charge for
the final out of the inning garcia
shakes his head a little bit coming off
the mound with those two walks but it's
a shutout first
inning one two
got him
and so that's the first strikeout of the
night
for the 25 year old right-hander i like
i like mustard on my fries i like
mustard on hot dogs
look at that yes look at that that is
you know what i'll be right back that's
it that's nice
need to center
laughed out like that i'll be right back
abandon marsh
markup will return in the fifth inning
two nothing
houston
[Music]
that ball sent high in the air
right center
myers gives way to mccormick and chaz
puts it away for the final out of the
inning
one two three inning for luis garcia or
through two it's two nothing astro
alvarez
walsh
junk
very clean one two three third
the long hold by garcia there goes wong
ball sent into center field jake myers a
diving catch now he bobbles it and he
throws to second they're gonna get the
force out at second
wong was heading back to first because
he thought myers made a great catch
he couldn't hold on but he still gets
the force out that ends up being a great
play by myers first he recognizes catch
thinks he's got to go back to first but
in dropping it he had his back to the
ball gets hung out to drive
out number two it'll bring up jack
mayfield
there's a line drive into right field
chaz mccormick a diving catch to end the
inning beautiful play by chaz mccormick
laying out into the gap and he made it
and takes extra bases away from jack
mayfield
some junk
to
two
fly ball
gosling has had to make a few runs to
that corner
and he makes the catch
chance and junk is retired 10th straight
looking good
and he walks for the second time there's
three walks allowed by garcia though
home fans aren't happy when
oh tony doesn't get a chance to swing
there goes ohtani pitches up
throw by castro and they get him on the
overslide
ohtani safe initially the call by nestor
seja but then altuve hung with it as he
got off the bag
for out number one what's interesting is
it looked like the ball beat him but the
pick
by jose altuve took his glove away from
the opportunity to get the tag initially
keep that video that's the first thing
shohei ohtani has done poorly this year
you're right
stasi sends one into right center field
chaz mccormick takes charge out there
and makes the catch for the final out of
the inning a hit and a walk caught
stealing helps louise garcia through
four leading two to nothing jason castro
will lead off here in the fifth inning
jason castro connects deep to right
field that ball's gone
jason castro home run number five on the
season
and the astros lead this game three to
nothing
do it jason this is a pretty clutch home
run because the astros haven't scored
since that first inning garcia now
facing keon wong
long around the bunt garcia on it in a
hurry luis garcia throw to first in time
to get wong with a bun attempt a one two
three fifth for garcia
as he is through five with a two hit
shutout astros leading three to nothing
now this is another growth moment too
for louise he knows he's been battling
himself tonight that has not been
a night where he's had his best stuff is
a back pick at first base and brandon
marsh is retired and now brandon marsh a
little too aggressive with his lead
you've got to see that ball kick away
and how about the astros being able to
take advantage of it
ohtani hits one sharply and julie
guriel's there nice play by euler to
beat ohtani to the bag luis garcia threw
six innings astros lead three to nothing
garcia a three-hit shutout
this becomes a huge at-bat for
luis rengifo
he did there it's lined to left and it
falls for a hit and the angels have a
run
[Applause]
did he go no swing
and that's a run
and the angels
doing some little things right and it's
3-2
line drive right field line and that's
fair and into the corner
one run scores long is in
march to the plate slides safe
captain jack
clears the bases
and here is ohtani with the man in
scoring position not an opportunity to
swing the bat again
ball in the right field mccormick will
make another diving catch chaz mccormick
making two excellent plays tonight
saving some damage for the astros but
some damage done five runs in the inning
the big blow of bases clearing double by
jack mayfield is now 5-3 angels
the astros will bring the tying run to
the plate in the form of jordan alvarez
into center field pretty well hit back
goes marsh near the walls off the top of
the wall rbi double by jordon alvarez
but it's now five to four on the ground
base hit to left field you're not being
waved around gosling's throw will be
late we're tied up at five
yuli curiel
on rbi base head with two outs at the
eighth to tie it up so here's otani
three walks one intentional with
mayfield the runner at seconds first
time with showa tommy to walk four times
[Music]
on the ground up the middle correa from
his knees makes the play home carlos
correa keeps the game alive
a great play on the infield by correa
who had to go down to his knees lost his
pudding and still made the throw home
giving on the season has a 388 era he's
found himself in a tough spot right here
with the bases loaded one out
to right played there by mccormick here
comes ohtani the throw home in time
ohtani wasn't tagged but now he will be
chaz mccormick with his third great
defensive play of the game
the opportunity lies in the hands of
jake myers
line drive base hit jake myers into left
field marwin will score astros take a
6'5 lead in the 12th on jake meyer's rbi
single
2-1 pitch is sent in the air to left
field down the line that's an rbi myers
is motoring around third he'll be waved
around he is going to be
safe at home plate a two rbi base hit by
altuve the astros are up three
[Applause]
bregman to right field deep plenty deep
enough to score altuve logaris puts it
away in front of the track jose can trot
home with the fourth run of the inning
alex bregman of sac fly makes it a 9-5
game
swing and a missed ball game over josh
james starts the handshake line for the
second straight night